[Music]
does it feel different to be up there
without a rope it's obviously like much
higher consequence
people who know a little bit about
climbing they're like oh he's totally
safe and then people who really know
exactly what he's doing
are freaked out I've thought about I'll
cap like four years then every year I'm
like that's really scary I'll never be
content unless I at least put in the
effort
El Cap is the most impressive wall on
earth it's 3,200 feet of sheer granite
it's the center of the rock climbing
universe
obviously I'd get interview questions
about it all the time Oh would you like
to do that you're like yes for sure
so you're a girlfriend now I heard as
awesome pretty much makes life better in
every way
it's really hard for me to grasp the why
he wants this but if he doesn't do this
stuff he'd regret it everybody who is
made free soloing a big part of their
life is dead now I haven't been injured
in like seven years I suddenly start
getting injured all the time what if
something happens what if I don't see
him again I could just walk away but
it's like I've always been conflicted
about shooting a film about free soloing
just because it's so dangerous it's hard
to not imagine your friend falling
through the frame to his death I think
when he's free to enjoy a feels the most
alive most everything how can you even
think about taking it away from somebody
no mistakes tomorrow
starting to come sight if you're pushing
the edge eventually
you find the edge
[Music]
I can't believe you guys actually
hey Jimmy do you copy things just
started quite
[Music]
super excited to have you guys here
today delighted to be able to talk to
you about free solo and your life
creativity and art and commerce and
everything so welcome thank you great to
be here it's very nice to be it's cool
I'm fascinated by your relationship both
personal and working relationship like
it's got to be a cool and at times I
would imagine challenging dynamic to
work together on a creative project or
projects that you guys both feel so
passionately about but and please
correct me if I'm wrong I feel like this
is like a divine pairing like the
expertise that you bring Jimmy and Shai
that you bring creates this beautiful
complement complimentary sort of set of
skills that allows both of your work to
like go to the next level and I think
free solo is a perfect example of that
if you so is it is it is the
manifestation of that yeah along with
what Alex brought uh-huh and you always
need the good subject yes but no I think
it's because he brought so much of his
craft to I'll cap that in kind of it
pushed Jimmy and and that and his high
angle team to bring their best and then
I pushed Jimmy and I his directors to
bring our best yeah but I mean yes the
free so is a very good example or
manifestation of how Jimmy our
partnership works yeah
and it's it is like the evolution from
Meru also I feel like climbing movies
have been sort of tiptoeing up against
the this barrier of trying to break
through to mainstream audiences it seems
like valley uprising was was a solid
attempt at doing that it didn't quite
get the penetration that I feel like it
deserved and then Meru went a long way
towards introducing mainstream audiences
to this world that you're so passionate
about that runs through your blood but
free solo is like
next level importantly came out yes no
but I think that you're you're right
that you know that cross-pollination
essentially from Chai's talents and
where she comes from
and her very strong background blast
with 15 years of you know serious
nonfiction documentary work combined
with you know what I've what I've been
doing for 20 years and you know I think
the biggest thing is that there's a lot
of trust there and you know sometimes I
wonder you know I
in some ways our our working
relationships on films on this film
it's almost simpler a convert are
compared to like being married and
having children are all those things
because we you know I think it's really
very easily recognizable like what we
each bring to the table on that level
and I guess it's it's it's similar ya
know it's hard I mean the it was
wonderful to bring our children to
somebody you know and it was definitely
part of my motivation was keeping
everyone together and bringing our
children to this wonderful place but now
in this part right like you've got both
parents on the road and that's hard yeah
so it's they're kind of those very
practical considerations that become
tough on us as a family
yeah but in the work in the work it's
really it it works because Jimmy and I
trust each other so much like I know
he's gonna make the right decisions when
he's shooting uh-huh he trusts when I'm
asking for something that I'm asking for
it for a reason like you know get that
shot and it's really important that we
film that um and it kind of works that
way and like just even on this film like
they're toiling away on the on the wall
with Alex for eight hours ten hours
and then Alex you know Alex it's down
but they're still up there kind of you
know huh gathering the ropes and getting
down and you know myself and a different
team like a Verret a cinematographer
would be there to talk to Alex about
life and love yeah his dad and you need
both I mean Jimmy you know on the one
hand like you're the only person who
could be doing what you're doing you
have the climbing expertise in the
background and the experience and you
have this incredible acuity with the
camera
your cinematographers eye and then cha
you bring the emotionality and the
narrative structure to this to really
take these extraordinary visuals and
turn them into a narrative that will
connect with people's hearts is that
fair I think it's fair but I think that
it's often easy to underestimate Jimmy
in that particular respect whereas I
think we have a great cheat so to speak
where Jimmy in this one bring such an
intimate knowledge of this world and I
often feel like just more of an
interpreter for like his instincts and
bring some exteriority to it yeah
because what I think would also is
strong that the film is it looks at
Alex's interior life and tries to build
a story while also aspiring to be
something that the core respects mm-hmm
right like that there's an authenticity
that is a hundred percent Jimmy yeah you
have to serve two masters right you
don't you can't alienate the hardcores
but you also have to make it appealing
and interesting and compelling for
somebody who knows nothing about this
world yes it has it has to make both of
us happy which is kind of nice right
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it works that
way I mean I think she's very accurate
about that in the sense that you know a
lot of the heart and the soul of both
Mara and free solo are ideas that you
know I've experienced are seeing or feel
deeply about because I've been in this
world and they're the great lessons or
the great conflicts internal conflicts
that I have suffered or people around me
my
peer-group have experienced you know
those are ideas that are really the
inspiration behind the films you know
the mentorship and the camaraderie and
the friendships that I felt so deeply
you know that have driven me to make
these films the task though is that I've
never it's you're so close to it it's
really hard to translate and like I said
I mean chai has been like being the
great interpreter she has been able to
kind of stand outside of it and be able
to tell that story in a way that people
can digest it right and that is really
powerful because I have not you know I
know it well and so those are the
conversations you know entire nurse
sitting there in the Edit room or when
we're making these films it's you know
she's just kind of you know her first
strokes editor usually very good and
then and then we start to kind of refine
those things and then also making sure
you know of course it has to also speak
to the core like there's no way I'm ever
gonna put out a film where I can't feel
proud walking into a room full of my
peer group yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
I would suspect that from your
perspective Jimmy you may think you're
conveying a certain point because you're
so close to it and chai can say yeah you
think you're seeing this but actually
I'm not getting it or the average person
is not gonna understand what you're
trying to convey it's more like that's a
wonderful point it's very important that
we achieve this other thing uh-huh
we get to that other thing and then I'm
like okay
let's go back to what Jimmy was saying
right um and see if we can make it work
within what we've done uh-huh series
polishing each other stones yeah yeah
and it's really important it's like this
concept that was incredibly important in
the film is a good example about
preserving Alex's experience of
Clym right like that's actually the most
important part of the task for for us
was to make sure that Alex enjoyed and
got what he wanted out of this but that
is a very elusive idea for people who
don't understand my right
[Music]
all right Jim's gonna follow you guys
down partway Claire's gonna pick you
guys up at the bottom of the gully going
into the base we're good we'll be
shooting on the wall she's ever once we
pass you guys you guys wrap it and hike
to the summit basically yeah Jimmy and I
have worked together for 10 years we've
climbed all over the world 70 we're
gonna be as chances yo the team that
Jimmy assembled are all professional
climbers the best possible crew for this
kind of thing its own way I'm like this
is kind of Awesome
you know it's kind of just like I get to
go plan with all my friends
[Music]
Mikey we should put someone right here
because if you lean out you can see the
entire frickin roof then let's just put
the hundred meter there in the corner
here doubled up
I've known Alex since he pretty much
started climbing in Yosemite in two
thousand eight or nine I've filmed Alex
a handful of times free soloing and then
we've also spent a couple winners
together down in South America
we the times added up I spent a lot of
time with him now so I'm scared cuz I
don't want to see anything happen to
Alex I mean it's one of the reasons I
almost said no to this job and I mean I
think Jimi went through the same stuff
of being like do we really want to be
part of this I've always been conflicted
about shooting a film about free soloing
just because it's so dangerous it's hard
to not imagine your friend Alex soloing
something that's extremely dangerous and
you're making a film about it which
might put undue pressure on him to do
something and him falling through the
frame to his death and we have to work
through that and understand that what
we're doing is something that we can
live with even in a worst-case scenario
it's an extraordinary accomplishment
this movie and it's a very delicate
tightrope walk because the simple fact
that you're present around him
inevitably influences him and that's
something you explore in the movie and
trying to remain adequately removed so
he has the space to do what he does and
in the way that he aspires to do it
while also trying to you know
responsibly document it so you can tell
the story I mean it's cube you know try
to solve that yeah and I love how you
kind of break the fourth wall with that
I mean you bring the filmmaker in the
filmmaking process into the actual
narrative of the movie and that really
elevates the the compelling nature of
the story that you're trying to tell
it's like that physics thing like the
simple observation of
of a subatomic particle is going to you
know change its position in nature right
and that's a micro example of what you
are experiencing just trying to be there
and I don't want to you know spoil it
for people that haven't seen it but that
gets played out you know in in a pretty
interesting way yeah no I think you have
it I mean it it's a lot also about
respect for the craft and the athlete
and you know I mean you you as an
athlete I mean you know that you don't
want to like take away from the whole
inspiration of the film you know by
being there and filming him it's always
been a conundrum in my field or you know
because especially in climbing and
probably in you know surfing and there's
this whole idea of purity right of the
of why you do it you know and and we
addressed that too you know you see
Peter Croft in the film being like you
know when people asked me if they could
fill me on an Astra man I was like no
not in yeah you know and in that moment
Alex lights up like a Christmas tree you
can see the respect that he has for this
guy and he can really hear what he's
telling him and Alex you can almost see
the gears in his brain turning like am I
making a mistake like yeah is this a
demonstration of a lack of integrity
because he's like look I have a film
crew with me like how do I do this and
the and the the the old sage is saying
like I wouldn't do that you know and
he's like you can see him like really
having a moment of reckoning with that
yeah
and Peter's like the great you know Yoda
for all writers you know for he's been
the one like the chosen one for four
generation and so his his words weigh
heavily for sure but it was interesting
because that decision to include the
filmmakers you know it was a hard one
and it it was one of those things that
we had to see
if we could make it work in a in a true
way on different levels right and
without it yes yeah and without it you
did you did a cut without that it was
always about degree but the filmmakers
right how much do we put in like and
also what is it really about you know so
it's it's not about the people are
interested in how we did it right like
that would be like the clear one reason
why you include them because people want
to see these guys hanging on ropes and
they're like how did they do this how
did they do this it was often a really
big question of Merit where I've we're
like they're like so what the fourth
person was filming it you're like no
where they were filming themselves yeah
but what's relevant about breaking that
fourth wall and bringing the filmmakers
into it is this question of purity like
what does it mean to do this from you
know a pure place of the heart and and
you're Jimmy you're like struggling with
that because you have these conflicting
drives right to respect what alex is
trying to do and also to have some
fidelity to the creative process of
telling an amazing story that will
inspire millions of people and the
ethical questions of what is right yeah
I mean causes right to die yeah what
does that mean you're shouldering this
incredible ethical conundrum this burden
of being respond not responsible
necessarily but a participant in
something that could be fatal and that
seemed essential to include yeah because
it also gets to the existential heart of
the movie itself right because in
dealing with that ethical question about
how what is our responsibility in this
situation you have to stop and think
about all the worst-case scenarios and
then think about the reasons why you
would make a film like this like what is
it is it justifiable like is that
worthwhile and you know it gets to then
that idea of Alex living a life of
intention and every day is exactly what
he's wanted what he wants to do he's
thought deeply about his own mortality
and his own death and he chooses to do
this
and and you know and for us that that
that idea like a life of intention makes
it worthwhile right
clearly we thought he would not get hurt
we trusted him deeply we had trusted him
to make the right decisions and not to
climb you know like you see in the film
I decide not to climb but it was you
know including the crew was a way to get
there to talk about this I mean also you
know what is has always been a solo
endeavor for Alex like he's in a van he
gets up and he goes and does this and no
one knows about it
maybe someone later you know reports it
on a climbing blog his greatest free
solo of his life ended up being about a
connection rather than being isolated
you know he had his best friends next to
him for a year and a half training
alongside him giving him feedback trying
to refine their shots while he's are
fighting his moves yeah um and all
saying like we're never gonna ask you
whether or not you're gonna actually
climb and we like you for who you are
you know you're you and we're still here
and any of this woman who entered his
life who for I think for probably the
first time in his life said I'm gonna
tell you how I feel about this but I
still love you
yeah you know and I'm not going I'm
gonna try not to go anywhere so I think
that it was this weird process for Alex
that it became about connecting with
people and communing with people sharing
an experience whereas it always had been
just this alone like loner endeavor for
him and the crew was a way of bringing
that to life by showing the crews
feelings about this and how they
interact with Alex was our way of trying
to get to that truth you know from a
psychological perspective he's such a
fascinating person unique and and really
funny you know that comes across really
well in the movie yeah in a you know
just a quirky bizarre kind of way and to
kind of echo what you said about you
know the solo pursuit of what he's doing
and then and then trying to grapple with
the community component
that the amazing variable is you know
enter stage left girlfriend which is
like a filmmakers dream right because
that just takes the narrative in a new
direction and makes it so much more
layered and complex and interesting if
it's stuck if it's stuck yeah yeah yeah
sure
perspective which I would imagine on
some level reflects your perspective
being in a relationship with Jimmy right
like what does it like to be in a
relationship with somebody who's
constantly going at who's compelled to
do these death-defying you know
adventures and I also loved how you
explored Alex's background particularly
his father and what his father struggled
with and I couldn't help but wonder like
well what what like remnants of that
lives within Alex like not that he is
you know has Asperger's or anything like
that but there's something unique about
his personality type that makes him
perfectly you know a perfect fit for
what he loves to do and it was really
important to us to explore like Alex's
origins like where he came from and
explore his most influential
relationships and you know Alex's dad
was a really tricky one because you know
Alex's dad died I want to say 11 years
ago or 12 years ago he dropped at an
airport of a heart attack and his
parents had gotten divorced about a year
prior to that and so there's this
absence right there was no one to speak
for Alex's dad who had belaid Alex for
thousands of hours in this climbing gym
and probably didn't say much but showed
up and belayed him right like Alex's
sister puts it the best being like I was
wonder if my dad had lived if he would
call and say a sentence about each book
he read instead of just telling me the
titles yeah his man didn't speak very
much and but he was very present so I
think there's definitely some a part of
Alex's dad and Alex are probably like
inclines him towards what he's doing
mm-hmm
um but I think that what you see if his
mom is very interesting you know this
idea of perfection is clearly like from
his mother yeah it's weird though cuz I
don't get that vibe from her she doesn't
strike me as somebody who's some kind of
taskmaster who's who's like you know you
have to be perfect but clearly that's
you know Alex's recollection or
perception of his upbringing well I mean
she's a published author she runs
marathons
she's a concert pianist and I mean I
don't know if she held him I think she
clearly held him to this standards like
good and good good enough isn't it
what's the other one it's good enough
isn't is the best one yeah yeah um but
also held herself to their standards
uh-huh you know but she grew up in a
different time right she's a Sacramento
teacher you know from New York who moved
in with this Northern California family
mm-hmm as somebody who's not a client
like I'm not a climber thought I've
watched a bunch of climbing movies I've
gotten to know some of the climbers and
I know lots of extreme athletes who do
crazy things and I went into the movie
and and I had met Alex and Alex you know
sat right where you're sitting and got
to know him a little bit so I went into
the movie thinking like I pretty I know
what this is about like you know I'm
familiar with the story and I get it and
you know it didn't take very many
minutes into the movie where until I had
this daunting epiphany like oh I don't
understand this at all
you know I this is like way more
complicated and intense and hardcore
than I could have ever imagined and
Tommy kind of says it in the movie he's
like you know people think oh yeah he's
gonna free solo that's what he does like
I just thought like you know he's just
he picks these routes and he just goes
up and it's the climbers who really know
who have the great appreciation for just
how super gnarly the whole thing is and
the diligence and the preparation the
attention to detail and the focus that
he demonstrates like that montage where
you have the voice-over of him reading
from his Diaries and you're like he has
every maneuver completely devoted to
memory all the way up this wall yeah and
it really boils down to those three or
four tricky moves to make it work for
him no absolutely I mean I think I I
know it's really almost impossible for a
non climber to imagine the scope of the
difficulty because it's hard for a
professional climber it's hard for me to
understand even how difficult it is
it's truly beyond what you know we were
even talking about it wasn't something
that climbers are sitting around the
campfire talking about you know because
it wasn't just it's just wasn't even on
the radar of a possibility it's just so
far out there and you know I've been
filming and shooting in this space for
20 years and and worked with many of the
best you know Peter craft included Dean
Potter and and many other incredible how
these people Conrad at the peak of their
careers and some of their top
achievements also in the ski
mountaineering world and snowboarding
and you know just a lot for a good mix
of extreme athletes and I just haven't
seen anything like it
you know when Alex came on the scene and
he kind of came out of nowhere when when
I first heard about him soloing
moonlight buttress and Half Dome I mean
honestly I you know didn't believe it I
was like there's no way somebody just
showed up and did that you thought it
was just apocryphal or somebody made it
up or yeah I know you know I had to I
did I dug I was like no way there's no
way and and El Cap is you know several
magnitudes more difficult than Half Dome
like many more it's just was so much
more difficult and I
I don't know if there's a good way to
put it I mean it's like yeah I think
about in the world of running like a
marathon it's like people are talking
about that person that's gonna break the
two hour right here right and then
someone shows up and runs a marathon in
under an hour
uh-huh you know wherever these like that
it's that crazy yeah
you're like what would who's who's
talking about running a marathon under
an hour yeah this is not physically
possible well that's all we so we
believe I sell we believe yeah and so
for a you know to imagine somebody it's
just it's a combination of not
necessarily physically possible but it's
just mentally there's no way someone
could keep it together like that it's
just unimaginable
so when how does this all come together
at some point Alex had to be declarative
like I'm gonna do this right to at least
you know get you guys in motion and
thinking about the idea of doing a movie
on this yeah well it's a funny story
because you know Jay and I were talking
about different potential films after
mehru
and and a few people had been
approaching us and so we kind of thrown
it out there that we were gonna you're
thinking about making a film about Alex
but it was more of a character portrait
you know a character study of Alex and
all his achievements up to before I'll
cap were already worthy of you know an
incredible film and so Ivan climbing
filming and traveling with Alex for 10
years and knowing pretty well that Chie
didn't know him as well so she wanted to
spend some time with him and he came out
to New York and I was on another project
out of the country or out of out of the
state but she was spending time with
Alex and he came to stay with us yeah
yeah which in itself is a great story
but we'll leave it at that
um what come on say that I can't he
wasn't alone that's for though all right
it wasn't to my great surprise and but
it was a for breakfast that he basically
just came out with it and said I'm
thinking about free soloing I'll
Catherine if there's a movie it should
be about that and she's like oh that
sounds great like as a filmmaker I was
like okay okay that sounds amazing great
that's big and then I told Jimmy and I
think I was the first person Alex ever
said it to out loud directly um and I
told Jimmy and you were like no way like
too risky we can't do it I was like he
didn't say that
visitors know it he did he said what you
know I made her repeat herself like
multiple times because I'm like he's
never said it to me he's never said it
to anybody I've known and obviously
we're very conscious of it cuz I you
know all of his friends in the back of
our minds you know we didn't even want
to think about it but back there we kind
of could tell like everything he had
been doing has been leading towards a
particular direction and the end of that
path there's a giant 3,000 foot wall you
know right and so unimaginable and set
against the backdrop in which a lot of
sponsors are you know dropping these
athletes because the risk factor is so
high and it's just too trepidatious for
you know a brand to be involved in
something that could lead to a fatality
right yeah cliff dropped all the people
whose solos as opposed to racecar
driving right correct
those cars flip all the time though for
the most part those guys seem to walk
away I don't know how that works but
yeah yes so so alright so you're like
there's no way right so your initial
your impulse was okay we can't make him
we can't be involved in this or you just
didn't believe that it was me we need to
let's let's take a step back here for a
moment and really think about this let's
let's we have to answer some very hard
questions you know is this ethical do we
trust him do we trust that we're able to
do a production around this without you
know causing him harm is he is the
production gonna you know the external
pressure of the production gonna push
him to do something he wouldn't want to
do it wouldn't normally do you know just
a lot of those questions and and there's
a couple months where I just tried to
shut it down and and stop thinking about
it but you know people were interested
and so we had that kind of make a
decision and I think six months into the
process which I and I were hanging out
with John Krakauer and you know the
author and he's a very good friend and
mentor really and you know we kind of
dropped it on him it was even hard to
say it's like hey cuz he was like what
do you guys thinking about next and we
were like we're thinking about and film
on Alex he's like oh that would be a
great film and you're like well he's
thinking about soloing I'll cap and I
remember we were walking down the
sidewalk and he stopped and he looked
over and he's like what cuz that John
yeah like yeah he's he's thinking about
soloing like happen you know John took a
minute to absorb it but then I was like
well what do you think and he just
looked at us and he's like well is he
gonna do it anyways and we were like
yeah probably you know he's like you've
been filming with him for 10 years you
know as well as anybody this is what you
do mm-hmm
you know do you trust anybody else to do
it mm-hmm no you're the only team that
could that could if he is gonna do it
anyway that kind of answers the ethical
dilemma aspect of it but then I would
imagine yeah you're like shaking your
head right I mean it doesn't let us off
that it doesn't let you off the hook but
I would imagine that there was then a
lot of conversations about what the
ground rules would be for how you would
capture this yeah we had to build
guidelines for ourselves what is that
free lawyer
um well I mean the the most poignant one
is like one could never ask Alex if he
was gonna freak out if he was ready if
he was gonna go any of it and if you
just stop and think about what that
looks like that's kind of mean it's a
staggering for a documentary film like
you've got how many people waiting
everyday in place ready to go your burn
rate being very hot right cuz that was
the other thing too I just I just I
guess I just assumed that there would be
a date on the calendar and that that was
gonna be the day that he was gonna do it
and everybody would be ready and it's
not it's like that well if he could just
you know do it went out whenever the
moment whenever you can felt inspired to
do it when he felt in his soul that he
was ready that it would just happen and
you had to be on standby the whole time
as an open timeline how long did that go
on for it felt like forever do this yeah
I mean obviously we we were seeing him
train and we could tell you know where
he was in his kind of fitness program I
mean the other thing that's like amazing
and I think that people take for granted
is that there's no coach for this
there's no diagram for how you train
best for free soloing I'll cap I mean he
invents it himself and so you know we're
also friends and climbing partners so
he's explaining like how he's training
and what you know so we're getting
indications you know clearly you know we
know what the problem areas are on the
climb you know obviously the free blasts
and you know the enduro corner and
clearly definitely the boulder problem
there's a bunch of other sections and he
he starts to work the route he starts to
kind of systematically tick off the
sections he knows that he's comfortable
with and like the monster off with like
they're all these pitches that are
notorious among professional climbers
you know professional climbers going to
free climb meaning climbing without
using points of aid
still using a rope but you know there
are sections on that route that are
notoriously difficult but the boulder
problem has a 10-foot section that's
incredibly difficult it's a very
intricate sequence you've got your right
hand on a crimp left hand on a side pull
and then you put your right foot on to
this dimple thing right hand is up to a
small down point crimp left foot goes
into a little dish and then you drive up
off the left foot into the thumb press
that's the worst hold on the entire
route so you get maybe half your thumb
on the hold then you've roll your two
fingers over the thumb switch your feet
left foot stems out to this really bad
sloping Blackfoot hold switch your
thumbs
and then reach out left to a big sloping
bread loaf type hold that feels kind of
grainy from there either karate-kick or
doubled I know to an edge on the
opposite wall in some ways it makes more
sense to do the big two-handed jump
because you're jumping to a good edge so
there's actually something to catch but
the idea of jumping without a rope seems
completely outrageous if you miss it
that's that the way that you took
something that would be very difficult
for the average person to understand and
translated it in a way that was not only
understandable but made it like more
compelling like oh my god here he is
he's on that at one point that is gonna
be this is the defining moment you know
like he did a great job of creating like
a tense narrative around those moments
thank you yeah thank you what is it that
I'm sorry go you know some of there was
some really valuable lessons learned of
Mary mm-hmm which made give us more
confidence and decisions we made about
how to do that where you could walk you
could see a lot of details you didn't
need to know what they were called you
didn't need it was all about his own
experience of that challenge and there's
you know spivot things like the thumbs
like you know no never forget those
thumbs what exactly it's called is it
called a pinch or whatever it doesn't
really matter right or pitches think
maybe there was a lot of information
that was okay if it was not included
uh-huh
when he finally went it's the moment and
he's beginning that was in the wake of
another attempt where he decides it's
not the right day and you guys make
adjustments and how you're gonna
document this because there's some sense
that that it's your your process was a
little bit too I don't know invasive or
in his face or something like that and
you have the cameras that are then like
in the valley
with these huge long lenses but you were
still I mean you seem to have plenty of
document you were on the wall and you
had the drones and all that kind of
stuff right like how what were the
adjustments that you made so that you
could still make sure that you were
getting the most riveting version of
this without being overly interfering
the main adjustment was that a rule that
always existed was like really enforced
about Alex could only see you if you
were filming him on and on from the
mountain right so but mostly was about
off for them yeah like that we had 15
people in the valley but he didn't know
that he didn't know that there was 3
rented houses in Foresta you know he
just didn't know the details of what was
going on and in order to minimize the
the pressure you know that all he knew
was that you know Jimmy er and Claire
Popkin or sit hanging out in his van you
know um you know and trusting us that if
the TAM time came we would be in place
um but in terms I think that there's
kind of a almost a misperception of what
it was like on the wall like when you
asked about the guidelines like the main
guideline also is that these are elite
pro climbers right you know Jimmy on the
team they are no longer criteria you
know they're elite pro climbers so that
dangling 20,000 feet to 2,000 feet in
the air is normal right and they're
comfortable there so it's not really a
question if they would ever drop
something or let a rope swing like that
their main job is to make sure that
never happens and I think that Alex
trusted you know really trusted the
people around him so that you know they
are dangling next to him and you know
the the mountain is is undulated so you
can be quite close without him seeing
you but he still needs to know that
you're there because no surprise is like
that's the worst thing for him and he
can hear you but um you know there are
adjustments like the boulder problem
remote cameras whereas a decision that
everyone came to together because his
issue was not about dying it was about
having a friend of his watch him die
yeah which in itself is remarkable right
this guy think
about someone else's emotional
experience of his own death the guy who
really had of always a very hard time
thinking about what anyone else felt but
also very undramatic about it like these
lights well you know like yeah I'm gonna
I got ya he's so bad he's like so mater
he's like it's great well yeah of course
I don't want to die but like you know
dying while my friends watching me well
you know yeah that would be kind of a
bummer you know he's so low-key about it
now it and it comes with the territory
when you spend a lot of time in that
space you know and and he says that all
the time he's like you know free soloing
gives me perspective because when I'm
standing in the airport line and there's
a guy in front of me just having a like
fit like he can you know he's like
well at least you're not gonna die right
and you can kind of keep it yeah I feel
like with Alex the you know the line of
questioning is always like you know
what's your relationship with fear and
death and all of these things and people
have a hard time wrapping their heads
around it and I kind of look at him as
somebody who has perhaps one of the
healthiest relationships with death
because he's so close to it all the time
that allows his life to present itself
in Technicolor right like he's able to
be incredibly present and like grateful
for the moment that he's in because he's
so closely connected to this thing
that's gonna happen to all of us but
which we all dismiss or try to pretend
you know isn't going to happen yeah no I
think you're absolutely right about that
and that that comes back to the the idea
of his you know intention in living
intentional living hmm I mean he is
acutely you know aware of of his time
and and that even for us being around
him for this long it has it has like
rubbed off you know has affected us
think in what way just he he walks the
walk you know I mean he he holds himself
to a very high standard and and then you
see him you know whether it's executing
on his climbing or if it's carrying a
dirty old you know a half liter Nalgene
not a Nalgene bottle bit like a Gatorade
or a bottle that he's had for six months
and you know he's put protein drinks in
it every day for six months and carries
him around
internationally the same old yes because
it's a perfectly good bottle and it
still doesn't leak and it still does its
job I mean the pants he's wearing on the
climb he's you know by the time he
climbs you you look at the bottom of his
afraid if they're afraid of him those
pair that pair of pants he did like a
legendary climb like years before one of
the great Alpine climbs of all time
where he did the entire Fitz Traverse
and Patagonia but anyways that's another
story but it was a tremendously
difficult climb and he shredded his
pants on it and then we saw him in New
York and we're like what are those pants
you're wearing and he's going on his
book tour and he's like oh these are the
same pants I wore my Fitz Traverse and
I'm going on a date in them tonight you
know I mean yeah to the point being like
you know he's very conscious of not
being wasteful yeah and you can't be
around that all the time without
starting to see you know your own
actions over the course of the day well
that red t-shirt is he's in LA in like
every photo he's wearing the same red
t-shirt well there's there's a logic
behind that too and I get that beyond
not being wasteful he also he always
wants to minimize variables so he wants
to wear the exact same clothing on the
actual climb that he has trained him
that's why in the morning he gets up and
he already has his muesli breakfast
built and the exact same
time.he for the month leading up to it
he was getting up at 4:00 in the morning
so that he would be regular mm-hmm at
5:00 go to the bathroom because he knew
he would start up the wall at 5:00 and
he didn't want to make it feel early and
he wanted have gone to the bathroom and
he wanted have had his breakfast and so
he so that when the day came he could
just go on autopilot and everything
would be the same it's amazing
you mentioned the book to her so Alex is
on this book tour speaking tour and as
was you talked about this at the
premiere when you're on stage like he he
was like on tinder or whatever and
trying to get a date like in every city
totally he actually did send updates in
every city it was I just wanted to raise
my hand and say like please read me what
your Twitter what your tinder profile
said like I would love to see like how
he characterized himself you know it's
that fancy site like the riot it's not a
Riya Riya Riya mine's your Instagram
feed and your Pandora like preferences
so it was basically heavy metal photos
of Alex shirtless hmm like in
spectacular place oh my god and it was
hilarious I could always be like what do
you tell these women that you do for a
little bit uh-huh
do you tell them that you live in a van
like yeah and it was amazing cuz we're
like great we have like documentaries
are never funny enough like I it's
always my dream to like make it very
funny documentary and it was a great
we've got a funny documentary which'll
help because the stakes are terrifying
on this film and it'll be a way to give
people a release and then sunny arrived
yeah so she moved into the van with us
we were there first
so but she is just a very special person
yeah it was it was a real turning point
for the film yeah and and one of the
things that you said that that evening
at the premiere was how important it was
to you into the movie to get that part
of the story right so what is it that
you really wanted to make sure that got
properly conveyed by virtue of that
relationship well I think in all of our
films and together being very mindful
and thoughtful about how everyone is
represented is really important and but
especially you know the women in the
film I mean the men too but it just
seemed that there are always women in
these particular types of stories have
always have often died been portrayed a
certain way it was like what was me I'm
staying at home and these women are not
like that
and Sahni is a very good example of
someone who is emotionally articulate
and self-confident enough to push back
on Alex but also find this place where
she can love him for who he is which was
like a revelation for Alex like he I
don't think he's ever had that
experience like I don't think his
parents looked at him outright I think
but so just giving her the space and
allowing the discomfort of what it felt
like when she pushed back on Alex right
before the client liked it because it's
an incredibly uncomfortable moment in
the film it makes you feel conflicted
about her conflicted about him but just
allowing those moments to live because
that was the right thing to make it was
the right representation it's honest
yeah it's so human it's so is she it's
sort of a passive-aggressive comment
that she makes it's like you know it's
okay if you don't do this you know and
you're like what's behind that the dream
I dreamt that you fell in the same place
the date and we know that he's climbing
he's gonna go free solo in two days she
doesn't know like those are really
difficult things to include and to
witness but it just seemed really
important for her character and for his
character and do you feel like Alex
compartmentalizes all of that or is he
really does that
on his I mean he's very clear like this
isn't going to influence my decision but
I would on a human level it's hard to
imagine that it doesn't impact how he
thinks about what he does I think if he
were to answer the question now it would
clearly impact what he does like they
were six months into a relationship he
was nine years into a dream and that I
think he I think he's being very candid
when he says that you know that's
understandable this was a dream he had
and then he met someone and where is
that gonna go they don't know um but I
think that if like they're still
together it's been three years and
that's a different type of conversation
now which is interesting and you know
I'm very happy for Alan right so what
does it look like now then so it do you
think it will have some level of impact
on what he chooses to do next yeah at
this point yeah I think so and and I
mean he's already you know admittedly
changed in in ways particularly he said
you know when I watched the film I see
these things that I say to her and I
think wow that's I need to work on that
I mean you know yeah he has a really a
deep sense of self-awareness around
these things I think he does and he
doesn't know it's a he doesn't sometimes
in the moment but then on reflection he
is all about self-betterment you know
all the time so it was whether it was
the eating vegetables or not knowing how
to hug and learning how to hug he's
constantly looking for best practices
but they they often feel very
unemotional and like ya know baat ik
yeah kind of throws people and his
friends but that makes it comedic - yeah
he's generally honest yeah he's trying
to be right yeah yeah you know he's
trying
I should be more emotional like oh no
I'm at the you know there's that point
in the film he's like I'm feeling quite
emotional you're right and that bad is
like him being emotional him being like
that's a
he's saying like I'm glad ya Spock is he
yeah his nerves right cuz some pens were
like hello right right right right well
the most uncomfortable he looks in the
entire movie is when he's standing in
that house in Vegas they're like
shopping and you're like I'm almost like
uncomfortable watching him you doing
that is like it's so out of place ya
know and he's trying he's like I want to
do this and he's you can you know he's I
don't know it just it was fascinating to
watch that without him saying anything I
think he's trying really hard and I
think I don't think alex is ever gonna
change feels this range of emotions
whereas most people feel maybe that
range of emotions I don't think that
will change for him yeah but I do what I
think is like I think we've been
thinking a lot as we're talking and
about this with other people and being
asked these questions I've been thinking
a lot about the motive his motivations
are the why in his idea of self
betterment cuz I don't think it's
necessary about self-betterment the more
I think about it I think you know like
what he says other people seem to enjoy
hugging I might as well try that I think
it's about communicating you know it's
about him trying to understand more
about what other people think having
more in common with people like there's
what would a normal human being do in
this situation you know and try and
trying to understand that experience
like normal people should have a house
like yeah should have a house he is an
alien that came to Planet Earth yes
studying what it means to be human
he wants to touch people and that's
really interesting to me what what
didn't make it into the final edit that
like was difficult for you to cut out
like some other aspects of this story
you know we had the real privilege of
having time when we made this film so we
worked like we tried everything but
there's no idea that wasn't tried and
the question is did we go back again to
try it like that's kind of the level of
how much playing we were doing like once
we got the film to a certain place to be
of
did we actually go back to that original
idea and see we could make it work and I
guess there's there's nothing I regret
that we regret yeah there's one thing
that popped up the other day that I kind
of began to regret which was the rock
there was a rock that fell in Morocco
yeah while they were climbing it was it
was a freak normal like it's something
that happens on climbs but it was pretty
dramatic but we didn't get it on camera
uh-huh and everyone was very shook like
shaken up and it didn't fit like we
tried everything and people were too
animated that didn't feel serious and
but it would have been wonderful like it
would have been very meaningful if we
could have made that work but there are
no regrets with this film like I think
that we really tried everything we could
and that feels good yeah you've been
traveling around screening the movie all
over the place it's getting you know
this incredible response right now from
all different kinds of people I mean you
guys must just be elated and delight
it's super exciting I mean I would
imagine you're gonna get Oscar
shortlisted you know you guys are on a
incredible trajectory what is the
experience been for you guys sharing the
movie and watching gauging like audience
reactions to it it's been humbling and
and we were so immune to this one we're
just so relieved that alex is fine like
the best day of this production is the
day he you know free so at El Cap and we
knew we were okay I can't imagine the
cathartic release it was it was such a
profound release and release and and the
thing is is I kind of had made a deal
with myself or with the universe or at
some point probably the month or the
week leading up to when he finally did
it which was that you know in those
moments when you're like the idea of him
pulling it off us filming it
successfully everybody being okay the
crew being safe
it seems so out of reach and I remember
thinking if if we ever pull this off if
he ever pulls this off like everything
else will be gravy like the film
whatever happens with the film is all
gonna be great
and and I you know I kind of go back to
that through this experience where I'm
like you know what we're so fortunate to
have been able to have this experience I
mean the process of the production was
really intense but it was like an
expedition where it's difficult what the
450 des expedition yeah yeah long oh
yeah but you know when you suffer
through this thing achieve you know what
seemed like an impossible goal and
there's you know a deep satisfaction
with that and so you know there's
there's you we tried and we're trying to
enjoy the moment
or try not to put too much into it I
mean we were putting everything into it
but I just mean like attachment oh yeah
I'm trying to stay centered about it
like we appreciate looking across an
ocean of heads that are like in a
theater grip watching your movie I mean
that feels great you know but yes we're
we're just we're very happy and grateful
so we were relieved when he did it and
then like the on like but instead of
like oh no we have to bring it now like
you know we've got a big you know it's
to him - Eddie's shown up in these
intimate moments like we have to make
the most of it
so then having cruise I mean everyone
was so committed and said then having
that time to really experiment and
explore and push was great but we became
immune right I think it's not it's just
a shot now when it like in the Edit room
was like oh that's a nice shot of the
mountain and when we went to tell you
right and washed it with an audience and
it was 10 o'clock at night it was the
world premiere it was a huge auditorium
and isn't looking at everyone from Tommy
Caldwell his wife Shaunie all our
cinematographers the producers sitting
there in one row
sobbing and experiencing probably like a
profound PTSD on some level he had this
exercise for three for two years it like
you don't feel anything in front of Alex
so no one like you put it away
and suddenly if you let it out and that
audience I know an audience really
during it and like I'm part of this so
it's just been it's been a real
privilege and like a great like I I
think we keep on saying to each other
and I keep on saying the Jimmy and Alex
a lot like this doesn't happen like this
is a moment and it's really special and
I wonder what it is about the film in
this moment and that's kind of an
interesting question yeah but um just
let's just enjoy it you know it's so
cool I mean it was screening at the
Cinerama Dome in Hollywood like when was
the last time a documentary period was
on the screen at that theater it's
insane it's an interesting story because
we were so it's all about where you
opened in LA right what theater we'll
take this movie and we couldn't book it
we couldn't book it we couldn't book it
in like three weeks before Arclight came
in and that was great like it's amazing
we got one of their screens at the
ArcLight and it was the Wednesday before
cuz everything got sold out so fast
there is a sense on our side like we
need more screens we need more screens
and like no one wanted to give us more
screens and on the Wednesday before one
person from our team was checking the
ticket sales and you know like tapped on
the ArcLight link and saw that they had
added it was like 14 more screenings on
Thursday and Friday including the
Cinerama Dome they gave us three screens
like the whole thing it just overnight
happened and that was almost that was
amazing like II know right like we just
didn't know yeah it's the highest per
screen average of like any documentary
or screen otherwise you just can't throw
a number like yeah yeah the wild thing
was as I'm watching it you get lost in
the narrative and and and you're just
like oh my god is it you know what is he
gonna fall is he gonna fall and I'm like
was sitting right there I know it he's
fine he gave me a hug practicing his
hugs so I was like it's all good yeah
and yet you still couldn't help but like
become incredibly tense and anxious yes
ya know even when you you know what's
gonna
yeah yeah no it's it's funny I mean the
number of people who come out of the
theater that are shell-shocked and just
look at you - I mean it's the number of
times I've heard my hands are still
sweating you know it's just I never
anticipated that in much of a reaction
and so I you know on the on this tour
it's it's fun I love going for the last
15 minutes and you know I don't watch
the movie i watch people mm-hmm and I
love watching that you know people have
their hands over their eyes or they're
gripping their partner next to them I
mean I think it's a great date movie
ya know people they're having each other
holding each other you know it's a
horror movie it's a comedy it's just
it's that has been something I didn't
expect I don't really enjoy from a
technical perspective I thought it was
really interesting trying to deconstruct
how you actually did this I mean there
is a mix of special effects that are
layered in and I couldn't really tell
where that began and like I knew you
used Google Earth yeah you have these
amazing shots where you're pushing in on
the wall yeah and it gave you like
because you see the wall and you're like
yeah that's a big wall but it's only
when you kind of zeroed in on them and
then you would see just how tiny you
know the bodies yeah we're against it
that you really got a sense of just how
the largess of of the affair yeah that
was definitely one of the challenges
because we've all been there you know
China and the whole team have stood
under El Cap and I've climbed up a lot
of times I mean it's this scale I mean
it is so big and it's really really hard
to translate that on yeah it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't get conveyed now
sorry worked very hard we spent a lot of
time it's a good example of our
partnership for gym where you come in
and watch these cuts and be like El Cap
doesn't look big enough and be like you
didn't give me a shot that makes it look
big enough
what's up they've had it for two months
they still can't make it look big enough
and it just cut it was the push of it's
a but we could have them no it's enough
information right and so finally it was
it was funny it was like we are process
I think it's fair to say that we keep on
tweaking to the bitter end you know like
I don't know until I ride him he was
even the final version of the movie you
know keep on tweaking and right before
we were locking it was just I was
walking healing the street and I was
like wait Google probably has better
images I wonder if they've given does
hmm and then they did and so so that was
very late it was very late and then it
took you know weeks to negotiate them to
give us the information and then the
files arrived and they were too big like
it was just assumed it was ingesting it
into the uh-huh took weeks and then but
then they were able to create this
three-dimensional mountain that worked
because that was the whole thing they
would only be able to get in a certain
in a certain tightness and that would
just kind of defeat the purpose
yeah you have to go other way or it's
like what's the point right well I mean
that was brilliant because that really
did make a huge difference in helping
you to understand the the gravity of the
whole thing what was uh what was like
the other than the simple fact that you
have a dear friend who could possibly
die like what is what was the hardest
part of this whole process I think there
was - you know I think that we both each
kind of focused on tackling our
respective you know spots I mean I think
for as the the Verte filming and just
getting putting in that time and getting
Alex and Sonny to just go totally commit
and give in and submit to the camera and
submit what you just have to leave it
rolling while they're not aware of yeah
sure yes the work itself
I do you think it was it was them it was
the pressure it was this it was no I
guess the idea that he couldn't die um
they never went away
um and that he woke up with every day
and all we are
and also like of our crew itself because
normally these types of high angle
shoots don't last for as long as ours
did and don't have that many people so
our exposure was significant yeah so the
day wasn't over until they were all on
the ground and that was a thing like you
know you kind of you'd hopefully not eat
before them and like it wasn't that
wasn't the point the point was like just
make sure they're back and okay yeah
well then tonight Morocco is Mikey down
yet are they down yeah you know I mean
Morocco was pretty extreme as an
experience like it's seven minutes in
the movie ups three weeks of shooting
and like pretty intense sit in vitam
pretty intense climbing environment so I
think but it was always just the idea
that Alex could die and did we make the
right decision as much as we believed we
did then please let us have made the
right decision and Alex make good
decisions yeah and there was a
possibility of course that he could have
decided to not do it at all mhm right
yeah yeah it's okay yeah that would have
been fine yeah but as Alex says but the
movie would just suck he decided not to
do it it would be a question of when I'm
not doing it this year okay we'll see
you next year like waiting around for
six years but you're getting kind of old
Alex that's okay like you know um he was
so obsessed with it that you just felt
like he was gonna happen
yeah and when he achieves it and he you
know gets to the top and he's like I'm
so delighted you know it's so there's
something really childlike and innocent
and and pure you know and beautiful
about because it's so honest to him you
know it could like funny too like what a
weird thing say I mean every screening
uh you know people laugh at that huh
because he he's accomplished this like
insane goal and he looks up and he's
like I'm so delighted yeah yeah yeah he
is he has this kind of way of thinking
about it too which is very smart I mean
he's very smart and he he's like you
know I can't build it up into
thing bigger than it is which would be
hard anyways but his whole idea is that
you know this isn't a stunt like he
knows he's put the time and he knew he
was ready and he wouldn't do it until he
was a hundred percent you know like he
wasn't gonna go for it fully if you he
didn't feel comfortable walking I'm to
it and going up it but his point because
people have asked him about it and you
know his response is like yeah I'm not
like jumping up and down her joy because
I you know robbed the bank and got away
with it he's like I knew I had it you
know and he always describes you know if
you're in a if you know the emotional
spectrum is one to ten
he lives between 4.6 and 5.2 uh-huh and
if he's super riled up he gets to like
5.6 yeah I know and so he's just that is
natural of his five yes you know that
smile his smile is oh yeah I mean it's a
million-dollar smile but it's really
just the accomplishment is just an
external manifestation of who he is and
what was within him the whole time you
know and it wasn't it's not a
destination oriented thing like that hey
I did this like now I'm done and you
know he goes back to the van and he's
like doing pull-ups like the same day
well you know it's just this is uh this
is who this guy is like through through
and through and through one question I
have for you guys is and I'm interested
if you answer this different what what
do you think makes a great documentary
like what are the elements that
differentiate like a good documentary
for from one that like really sings for
me it always is about the story and I'm
probably the character I know we make
these visually you know
we have very high expectations for
herself visually but you know if it's
when I was just going with our editor
through like my earlier films and went
back give him back to watch my first
film um you know and that was shot on a
you know tiny mini DV camera by me and
you know and the characters in that film
are just remarkable you know and so and
their story was amazing
so I don't you know I think of things
like street fight you know Marshall
Curry's film that he shot on another
mini DV camera about Cory Booker you
know first yeah race and you know I I
think it you just have to have that
story in that character and it'll make a
wonderful film and then the other part
of that is clearly the gays like the ga
ze of it like that
that your own intention as a filmmaker
is it will very much define that oh you
know and do you think those principles
apply whether its narrative or
documentary I mean you you've done a lot
in in documentary filmmaking you've
worked with all kinds of interesting
people and made many other films but you
also work with Mike Nichols on closer
right like what do you learn from I mean
a master storyteller that informs the
films that you make now I mean it's
story I mean it was always story for
Mike and character I think those are his
two things I think his process was
really interesting like he still
rehearsed he would work with the writer
in rehearsal with the real actors saying
their lines and like breaking it apart
and how he really focused on those
performances and he I mean Mike is it
wasn't genius like the amount of thing
like he was the type of guy that in the
room he would notice what the person the
coroner was saying and if it was
something of you know worth he would no
matter who you are he would engage
because he would remember that that
person had said it and and for him he
was always story and characters yeah the
same thing yeah
Jimmy yeah I mean I how can I argue with
that I don't know but I but you come to
it from a more of a DP / special sure
yeah I mean visually of course I mean I
love you know creating the visuals yes
part of what I do and who I am but I
always kind of go back to what I
personally loved about films and you
know for films that really moved me
emotionally that made me feel something
who were your guys like who are that I
mean like the most recent example I
don't know I mean there's I guess this
is more narrative but yeah I grew up
what well I I'm just trying to think of
something most recent like I I loved a
Hurt Locker I loved Damon Zell's
whiplash - I mean that you seen first
man yet and we saw a first man I loved
Senna - if so there's two things that I
I love as when you're really moved
emotionally I remember watching the
power of one back you know there were
some films it later
that's the me feel something deeply I'm
like and I love that experience because
you're being transported somewhere and
you feel something and I always want to
make films where people feel something
you know where they're like moved
emotionally and I also love being
transported in a world and I think Senna
did this for me where you're like yeah a
racecar driver I know it's kind of
dangerous and like I'm not that
interested in racecar driving and I came
out of that movie being like you know I
was like Formula One is so gnarly am I
so push your edges so I get what they're
pushing for and I understand the
ambition and like what it means so those
kind of things I have you know for
marrou
the previous film like those
I remember Hurt Locker and Senna
informed some of my mm-hmm thinking
around I love the emotional yeah
what's interesting about what you do
though is that for most documentary
filmmakers that are sort of on the
periphery and I suppose for this movie
you had to be more on the periphery than
you usually are but but generally it's
an immersive process for you where you
are participant and observer at the same
time which is unique which is unique
like you're you're telling the story and
you're part of this story as well yeah
and I feel like it's always because I'm
feeling deeply on these productions you
know I feel something very deeply when
I'm in it just because you are in it and
it's I don't think it's necessarily
special but but you know it's important
for me you know to bring that feeling
and hopefully share it you know bring it
through the screen and give it to to the
people watching it and that's thankfully
how to try to help like Jimmy is like a
literal translation of that but I think
that most like waffle makers are all
authors like you are active participant
in what you're doing and that that's
like a responsibility but at least with
Jimmy like it has to be a palpable it
take a palpable thing that you're you're
watching it and he as he's doing it what
it what do you want audiences to take
away from this movie or do you want to
just allow them to have their own
experience but like what is your do you
have an intention behind that yeah it's
kind of what I took away from Alex's
story which is here is this incredibly
scared kid he's a loner who began
climbing without a rope because it was
scarier to talk to somebody to be as ask
him to be his partner and who you know
was intimidated by vegetables scared of
hugs scared of intimacy any intimacy and
methodically taught him
you know to work through his own fears
and that is very very moving to me
because I feel like everyone has a fear
like that we're not that extreme maybe
but there are lots of things that scare
us and the process of him working his
way through his fears is what like he
places himself in the most fear inducing
scenarios a human being could imagine
well I think it's little by little right
like he practiced hugging in the Sun he
introduced one vegetable a month right
and yes and then he decided that he
wanted to climb this mountain so he
began he spent you know 15 years of his
career preparing for doing something
bigger and badder but I think he also
has this courage that I hope people take
away from the film like it's very
inspiring what what he's done and how he
looks at it and how he and also this
communal experience that happens it's
about communicating and courage and
doing something so yeah and and what is
it that you think makes him unique like
if you had to define what makes him
special and distinct from his peers
within that community and even in
general I think that his absolute like
adherence to a life of intention makes
him incredibly unique yeah um like that
is real and it and inspiring its
uncompromising its inspiring and then
you add to that that he's clearly a
genius like he's an absolute genius but
he's also has this discipline that is
unheard of like it is after it's
disciplined I mean that's what makes him
great because I'm sure Tommy could be a
better climber than he is like but alex
is like discipline just helps him move
through all these challenges right like
his talent is on par with his peers but
his talent isn't the deciding factor
it's not like he's more talented than
anyone else it's something else not not
necessarily physically right that's what
I meant to say
I mean he's unmatched like and his
mental capacity to I mean we always kind
of say that it's his one superpower yeah
he has a superpower that he could exist
yet it's it's like he's able to take his
emotional mental physic
spiritual sells and dense them to steal
them down into one thing that's working
in perfect unison yeah I think you're
very that's a very good observation
because if if you look at soloing it is
it is the purest form of climbing right
I mean you are stripped to even not
having a harness and ropes it is the
purest expression I mean maybe he could
do it naked but otherwise like it is
like the purest expression of climbing
but you know and saying it's like it's
and and he's like that he's like that
should be pretty fun yeah it made me
think of the guy in the bunny suit on
the wall or yeah right yeah no but like
you said he distills you know it's all
about efficiency distilling down to
these very you know everything to its
finest form essentially and that is is a
constant onion running in his head yeah
for everything what do you think he's
gonna do next
I think he's you know we've had a few
conversations about as this thing
starting to blow out you know and get
bigger and bigger talking about you know
how you manage it and what you know and
we talked a lot about taking taking his
time you know there's no rush to be
inspired again but and there's no need
to force anything unless he's inspired
by it and so I think he's kind of biding
his time I think he's gonna pivot a lot
of his attention towards his foundation
which he really believes in you know his
belief is like there's no use in being
famous if it's not being used for good
and so he has like a good pivot point
for it and you know climbing has a lot
of different expressions speed climbing
like he finished this climb went to
Alaska did a big outline climb went to
Antarctica and we went to Antarctica to
you
he went to broke the speed record on the
nose I mean he's actively training and
climbing because he has other climbing
goals but does he need to do another
bigger solo I mean probably not I don't
know I mean if he's least a higher
played his man card I mean anything to
prove to anybody for himself
really it's just his eternal you know
drive to express himself yeah and then
the funny thing is it's like he did it
for himself you know it wasn't even
trying to play the man card yeah I mean
the beautiful he has that beautiful line
in the movie where he's like look it's
more important to me to do this what's
important is that I do this and do it
the way that I want to do it not that it
be documented yeah paraphrase I don't
remember
yeah I'm lying but I don't care if it's
yeah yeah what about you guys
what are you gonna do next it's a good
question you set the bar pretty high
that's I mean I have to seesee all that
pressure but after Mary you felt that
pressure profoundly because it's like
doesn't get much you know we fell in
love while making merry we had a child
we Mary was made for nothing and then it
was it made all this money like there
was this like thing that you eat could
we ever marry with Shakespearean as a
film so I'm just excited to do something
a little different like we we be I'm
working on a film concurrently about
Christine Tompkins and Tompkins
conservation and Christine tongue is in
the lead Doug Tompkins and it's kind of
like an out of Africa for our generation
as I gets building on this idea of
intentional life of intentions a little
more radical even than free soloing
there's a mountain but not a main
mountain it's like a whole new thing for
Jimmy but these are his best friends
uh-huh so and it's just I'm excited too
I've never made we've never made a film
about someone who's passed already and
so Doug Tompkins had died several years
ago tragically and like that's kind of
an interesting challenge and the
characters are so rich on this film and
there's a lot of archival so I mean I'm
excited to kind of tackle with something
else while we are exploring what else is
in our future yeah but it's deeply
meaningful
and to try and weave you know Yvonne
Shannara and that and Doug and and Chris
and Rick Ridgeway that circle of friends
have been well clearly an influence on a
lot of people but you know have been
very dear kind of mentors and friends
that I've looked up to you
for a very long time and I've gotten to
know for over the last 15 20 years and
our kids get to go to Patagonia it's
great we have yeah we love them deep
family it feels like a lot of you know
inspiration now meaning behind it you
know I I don't want I only want to well
as you can imagine you you throw down a
lot for documentaries yeah and yours
basically making a decision for the next
few years however many years yeah we get
faster though I found like I've this is
my sixth film now this would be my
seventh I feel like every film it
basically cut the ratio in half but
isn't this doesn't the story dictate
that sure yeah you can also get better
yeah well you have I mean there's
something magical in the alchemy between
the two of you you know Manhattan born
and bred
Minnesota Wyoming climber like it's a
you know it's an unlikely pairing but
there's something really cool on how you
complement each other come from Chinese
dagger mom's like our mom's probably had
a lot in common huh and it's yeah like
I'm half Chinese if I had like this
whole nice Hungarian Brazilian like
profess Oriole dad right who like very
much wants me to do what I believe in
whereas my mom still huh will be like
it's not too late to go to bed school
yeah yeah if your hand but I think my
mom is not a tiger mom she's not Chinese
but she still asked me if she thinks I'm
gonna go I'm 52 years old I'm gonna go
to medical school
anyway I'm gonna get a real job I get
that a lot
it's a thing but it's definitely this
deep we know where each other comes from
when it comes to the really important
things uh-huh and that's something
that's very safe and warm and special
for both of us I think but you have you
have this Upper East Side
you know rearing people she had people
say this like it's like a poison right
my parents for immigrants I was
conceived in LA okay I was a professor
at Columbia you know it's just it was a
good place to raise kids the same way
that Jimmy's parents had read that
Minnesota was a good place to move to
raise children so there were librarians
at the University of Minnesota Mankato
so it's like we it was um I think New
York City has like bad rap where I would
more say like it was this opportunity to
go to an amazing girls school you know
that shaped everything for me and let us
eat Chinese food every weekend you know
like it's like the city with everything
but both my parents worked and we're
also really dedicated to my brother and
myself so it did I don't know and Jimmy
you have academic parents but Tiger mom
like how do you get you know I don't
have time to explore the whole backstory
we're gonna wrap this up we're highly
attuned to excellence
yeah Jimmy played till book 15 of Suzuki
okay like he's a mean we still have this
violin it is amazing like it's this big
yeah thank you
high school and then I picked up again
Jimmy he was like oh like you mean swim
champion of Minnesota huh there was no
drive there
and martial arts I basically competed
and you know yeah you were Simon yeah it
meets every weekend but they were
throwing in martial arts competitions on
top of oh wow and and playing the violin
yeah and plan to do it all so he was
ready for the mean streets of Manhattan
huh yeah so what do they think of what
you're doing now well they both passed I
don't have I'm sorry that yeah but they
you know they got to see I'm very happy
they got to see you know they once I
started publishing and I was in the
magazines and stuff like that you know
huh my mom had a stack of magazines this
big with little markers sticking it out
of them you know in the living room and
I'd be like that's so embarrassing can
you put that away
but it's like she just put all of them
she was yeah and your dad was pretty
proud of our two kids yeah that was also
like a big event in everyone's lives
yeah it's cool all right well I got a
release you guys to your lives but I
thought a good way to kind of close it
down would be to maybe impart a little
bit of inspiration or wisdom to the
aspiring filmmakers out there I mean you
guys have achieved something
extraordinary with the work that you
have done and I have no doubt will
continue to do for people out there that
are interested in either narrative or
documentary filmmaking and are
struggling to figure out their voice or
how to get going what can you say to
those people I think that making phones
is hard so if you're gonna make a film
it should be about something that is
incredibly meaningful to you you know
and that's that's that's why you would
use your voice so that that meaning you
know find that meaning you know and it's
okay to wait until you find it or like
bumble along the way and find it later
but it just it should be meaningful yeah
I I mean I would echo that I mean it's
really about finding it's a bigger
question it's about finding your purpose
and finding what gives you meaning and
finding things that you're inspired and
passionate about because like I said
it's very hard to make films but when
you find something that gives you that
drive and purpose it's a lot you have to
be relentless regardless you know it's a
lot easier when you find something that
has a lot of
I find it cool all right I think that's
a good way to end it you guys yeah I
didn't go so much for having you here
very sincere um thank you
it's an extraordinary accomplishment
free solo we should have been called
solo by the way except for a pesky Star
Wars film that happened to come out
right Alex don't mean like that was the
original title when we tried we were
like who will fly in defiance and now
now that Nat Geo is just bought by
Disney like why couldn't we but um
legal legal couldn't wouldn't let us do
it and then ultimately I think that free
solo solved a lot of problems for us
like narrative problems think it was
still on the loose of concept for
everybody is free so say we just call
the movie free solos and suddenly like
all the problems went away yeah yeah you
know I can't imagine imagine it being
called anything else yeah yeah like I
said extraordinary accomplishment it's
it's funny it's riveting it's harrowing
it's beautiful I saw Brett Morgan
tweeted that you should be getting a
cinematography Oscar for it which is a
high praise from a master documentary
filmmaker I think all that praise is
well-earned it's super cool and exciting
to see the response that the film is
getting I think it's only going to
continue to build and the beautiful
thing about documentaries is they they
they get that opportunity to build and
find their audience and this has got to
be it's a great time for you guys it's
so cool so I'm excited for you I look
forward to seeing you on the stage at
the Oscars we'll see fingers crossed
that's nice hey man I had Brian Fogle in
here last year around this time so
anything is possible and for those that
are listening you haven't seen it yet
please make a point of seeing it and you
will you will not be disappointed cool
is there is there is it everywhere
nationwide right now and what about
internationally it is opening in England
December 14th and more more countries to
follow hmm but it is at its widest this
weekend it's in 400 theaters so people
should go out and see it yeah and if
people want to learn if this is
brand-new to people and they want to
learn more about it where's the best
place for them to go online free solo
film comm uh-huh
and we're anything else coming up you
guys doing talks or anything like that
where people can find you and track you
down and stop you our instagrams yeah
I'm at Jimmy underscore chin and look
for years that you didn't have any posts
unless I had it wrong she changed she
just joy oh you changed I everyone has
convinced me to change it from like the
name that used to make me happy to my
own name so it's cha Vasarely jive s
early well and I'll put links to all
that stuff up and free solo film there
yeah all right cool thanks you guys
thank you
[Music]